do you think that that is something that
most people are comfortable with in
terms of quote being broke versus having
that 40 hour week job or they know what
they're gonna get usually uh I wouldn't
say they're comfortable with it but they
understand it they get it and you know
you're out here with that teetering on
friendly to your own competitive
atmosphere all the time but at the same
level everyone's everyone at one point
is pretty much gone through what every
up-and-coming whatever is going through
so happy with it no but understanding
and realize that it's part of the nature
of the game yeah and then go back to the
social media thing that's why when
something good happens you want to shout
it from the mountaintops because you've
had so many nose and so many rejections
and so many challenges and risks that
you failed at unfortunately before you
get that whatever good one it's all
every time someone succeeds out here
it's always a success or era you know an
underdog story in some way shape or form
really so for someone who's super
organized and sounds like plans
everything which is awesome it's awesome
I wish I could be more like that how are
you with not being certain about certain
things in terms of money and what's
coming in next oh yeah it's I understand
it your look so well I think that's why
I got into a lot of the writing and
producing because I can take care of all
that like I can make it happen and I can
put it together and I can pitch it and I
can see what we can get the acting
portion is fantastic I absolutely love
it but there's so much out of control
you know whether you're you your hair is
too long hair too short you're not tall
enough yours you know whatever it may be
actors are more than likely the last
piece of a puzzle of a TV show
especially when it comes to commercials
and it comes down to the littlest
intricacies so you have to understand
that you can't take those personal and
so in order to hopefully have that be a
full-time thing you could have a little
bit more control with stuff that you
write and produce on your own so to be
able to have that aspect and your
repertoire per se and to be able to make
money off of that going back to that
kind of hands in a bunch of different
baskets to see which one takes first has
been beneficial to me put it this way
like I always say when it comes
musicians I'd always respect somebody
that writes their own music and plays
Don instrument as well as sings more so
than someone that just possibly just
sings nothing against anything but I
just think like that triple they're not
saying I'm a triple threat by any means
that's not what I meant but just someone
that has they're doing a lot of
different things and just they love
music so much they're going to learn
every instrument and learn every note
and learn how to sing alone how to play
guitar same thing when it comes to
entertainment industry if you like
acting then you should also like writing
and producing and just being a part of
it and a lot of the most successful
people out here are behind the camera
just as much as they are in front really
you